est ce qu'un ministre a dit que l'on
pourrait ouvrir désormais la pma est ce
que cela a été dit de la manière la plus
nette est la plus claire en plus par un
ministre qui est porte parole du
gouvernement
nous attendons une réponse il me semble
que la représentation nationale dont il
me semble que la tradition même dans
notre assemblée c'est que quand on pose
une question au gouvernement on puisse
avoir la réponse du gouvernement quelle
que soit la réponse d'ailleurs mais vous
nous la donnait pas vous nous dites
partait quitté l'hémicycle
c'est acceptable non plus sans
conséquence et d'ailleurs nous ne
partons pas et si nous partions nous
reviendrions de toute manière mais il
est clair aussi que nous avons posé une
question bon chacun de ces sur les
propos de madame belkacen elle qui est
si prompte à développer les arguments du
gouvernement actuel
qu'elle vienne madame belkacem ça doit
pas être un effort considérable en fin
de semaine elle est pas un tahiti lé pa
tombouctou bon par conséquent qu'elle
vient de nous dire vraiment ce qu'elle a
dit c'est ce que nous voulons c'est ce
que nous attendons
est-ce que vous m'autorisez à prendre
trois ou quatre minutes pour juste avant
de vous répondre vous raconter une
histoire qui est liée à la réponse qui a
lié à la réponse j'ai fait ma scolarité
à cayenne en guyane de l'eau sur l'autre
rive de l'océan atlantique en amazonie à
cette époque lointaine qu'évidemment les
jeunes de 20 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître
après le baccalauréat il n'était pas
possible de se suivre des études
supérieures je suis donc venu ici à
paris pour faire mes études supérieures
à l'univers de vous j'avoue je vais déjà
rencontré l'amour au lycée à kayes et
admet enfin bon
c'était quand même du bonheur parce que
il y avait beaucoup de bibliothèques
beaucoup de librairies beaucoup de
baisse est une association d'idées par
rapport au bonheur donc voilà j'ai
trouvé le bonheur de la littérature des
librairies des marchands mais évidemment
loin c'était une époque où il y avait un
vol aérien par semaine le la traversée
se faisaient plus souvent par bateau
d'ailleurs et puis et puis évidemment un
téléphone et une fois par trimestre donc
forcément j'ai eu quelques mélancolie et
j'ai cherché du fromage gruyère une
histoire vous paraît bizarre j'ai
cherché du brumath gruyère j'en ai
acheté une première fois il ne m'a pas
plu une deuxième fois il ne m'a pas plu
une troisième fois
j'ai posé très clairement la question
est-ce que vous avez ce fromage gruyère
qui piquent qui picote et j'ai découvert
que le fromage gruyère ne pilote pas
sauf que il arrivé en guyane par bateau
avec deux mois de retard et que par
conséquent celui que j'ai connu dans mon
enfance picotait c'est exactement ce qui
vous arrive est un déclaration de madame
najat vallaud-belkacem madame najat
vallaud belkacem s'est exprimé il ya
trois mois sur la pma depuis jeudi soir
depuis vendredi
vous nous mettez vraiment en le mot
m'échappe
vous voulez absolument que nous
répondions séance tenante sur une
déclaration que madame vallaud-belkacem
biais de faire ça fait trois mois que
madame vallaud belkacem ne s'est pas
prononcé sur la pma voilà donc ça veut
dire que votre fromage gruyère
ils piquante et puis comme sur la paix m
je vous rappelle que nous avons un texte
est que ce texte un périmètre précis que
ce périmètre c'est le mariage et
l'adoption
ouvert aux couples de même sexe à droit
constant
si l'on transforme fondamentalement est
substantiellement le fondement autrefois
juridique du mariage en lui substituant
un fondement simplement sentimentale ont
réduit de mariage est une simple
reconnaissance sociale de l'amour des
couples de même sexe
or cette transformation ouvrira la voie
à d'autres revendications qui seront
cette fois complètement fantaisistes
mais tu existes déjà mariage avec des
objets c'était aux états unis où une
américaine s'est marié avec la tour
eiffel mariage avec soi même aux états
unis toujours mariage à trois comme au
brésil mariage avec des animaux comme en
australie
ça vous fait sourire mais je suis
contente de voir que ça vous choque